Hola Muy Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español la Copa del Mundo
Qatar 2022 dejó varios debates y también
polémicas como por ejemplo el hecho de
que en el país anfitrión la
homosexualidad sea considerada ilegal y
también la muerte de migrantes a cargo
de la construcción de los estadios entre
otros temas pero este mundial dejó
también imágenes y hechos que nos hablan
de nuevas masculinidades jugadores por
ejemplo diciéndose de manera pública y
sin reparos que se aman manifestando su
afecto en medios de comunicación en
redes sociales llantos de emoción
también de tristeza otros futbolistas
hablando por ejemplo una entrevista
sobre su salud mental y también un
mundial en el que la participación
femenina cobró una fuerza que no había
tenido en otras copas mundiales vamos a
hablar sobre masculinidades y también de
un fútbol de construido junto a Mónica
Santino
de técnica de fútbol ex jugadora una
militante que alza su poderosa voz para
promover la inclusión de las mujeres en
el fútbol lidera además la organización
la nuestra fútbol feminista Mónica
Santino Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en esta entrevista
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación muy
muy contenta de poder conversar con
ustedes esta tarde y poner un poco de
luz de pensamiento no absolutamente Esa
es la idea Mónica Bueno hay unas nuevas
masculinidad o nuevas masculinidades que
se manifiestan en estas elecciones en
algunas al menos como por ejemplo la
Argentina y que se hayan visto en Qatar
sí creo que empezamos a
atisbar algunos cambios no con respecto
a esa construcción masculina en el
fútbol pensar que el fútbol tiene más de
100 años de historia por lo menos en los
tiempos modernos son lo que es el inicio
de nuestros clubes o los lugares donde
los futbolistas empiezan y siempre fue
un deporte un sitio un lugar donde se
construyó una idea de masculinidad muy
ligada al pensamiento patriarcal no a
esto del valor la valentía el no llorar
el no poder manifestar ningún ningún
tipo de sensibilidad y después bueno no
algo con lo que nosotros hacemos luchado
toda la vida que es esto de que las
mujeres no pueden jugar y no lo hacen
También como los varones no entonces
creo que de un tiempo esta parte con los
cambios con el avance del fútbol
femenino con el movimiento de mujeres en
la calle como ha ocurrido en Argentina
sobre todo en los últimos años desde el
2017 2018 para acá empezamos a sentir
algunos cambios también en el fútbol con
respecto a esto y sobre todas las nuevas
generaciones de futbolistas y creo que
es algo saludable No creo que que viene
bien Viene bien Escuchar jugadores que
dicen que se quieren entre sí porque
tiene una idea de grupalidad
completamente diferente jugadores que
admiten que van a terapia o que tienen
un psicólogo para ayudarlos a solucionar
determinadas situaciones que se dan en
el campo de juego y afuera Entonces si
bien No es que está toda la tarea
concluida y que ya estamos asistiendo a
un nuevo fútbol me parece que es muy
importante ponerle la lupa a algunas de
estas cuestiones que aparecieron en
Qatar como el inicio de un camino no
como algo que que tenemos que seguir
transitando recorriendo nuevas
masculinidades diversidades en el
deporte distintas identidades en el
deporte y pensar también la idea de
grupalidades de ahí no yo creo que algo
algo muy notable para esta selección
argentina aparte de su título del mundo
es un cuerpo técnico o un director
técnico
apoyado en otros compañeros también No
ya como salirnos un poco de ese rol del
director técnico que arengaba decía lo
que había que hacer y su última palabra
era la que valía no y nada más acá hay
una conformación de un equipo de trabajo
y evidentemente también hablar de ese
rol de la dirección técnica desde desde
un lugar interdisciplinario no donde las
cuestiones que tienen que ver con lo
mental con lo espiritual con considerar
a las personas personas humanas también
se fue abriendo paso y esas son buenas
noticias sin dejar de pensar todo lo que
lo que falta transitar para realmente
llegar a una transformación hablemos de
otro tema Mónica hablamos ustedes recién
de identidades
disidentes también no de alguna manera y
vimos un hecho particular en este
mundial que tiene que ver con la
selección de Alemania no y su apoyo al
colectivo
lgbt iq a ellos no le permitieron
utilizar sus brazaletes tuvieron un
gesto simbólico no de taparse sus bocas
en este sentido Le quiero preguntar si
está dejando de ser quizás una
característica del fútbol esto de
construir las identidades masculinas en
contraposición a un otro considerado
siempre por lo menos bajo los términos
gay o verdad
Sí sí No históricamente esas palabras
son usadas de una manera peyorativa y de
una forma que está ligada al bueno Esto
es un deporte que no te pertenece que no
puede jugar cuando en realidad estamos
partiendo desde los feminismos a hablar
del deporte como un derecho humano y
cómo garantizar el acceso al deporte Al
conjunto de la población Más allá de su
identidad sexual su orientación sexual y
como quiera como quiera hacer no dentro
y fuera de la cancha para nosotras el
fútbol se constituyó en una herramienta
muy muy importante para combatir la
violencia de género cuando una una joven
una niña o una identidad diversa separa
en la cancha levanta la cabeza pone la
pelota bajo la suela se da cuenta que
maneja un grado de poder y voltea una
cantidad de prejuicios que hasta ahí
parecían verdades inamovibles Entonces
lo de la selección alemana es muy bueno
por el grado de visibilidad que tiene es
histórica
una selección que ha salido campeona del
mundo de tantísimas veces y que esa foto
de esos jugadores tapándose la boca tuvo
todo un recorrido entonces creo que es
muy importante a nivel de los mensajes
que estamos diciendo y mandando y mucho
más cuando un deportista se compromete
con estas cuestiones No porque si no
pareciera que el deporte no tiene nada
que ver con cuestiones sociales y
políticas y sí tiene que ver con
cuestiones sociales y políticas porque
el deporte en sí es un hecho cultural
social y político Entonces cuando los
deportistas nos animamos a levantar
estas banderas los mensajes que se
generan o las ideas que se empiezan a
generar son de cambios y una
transformación y son importantísimas
Entonces ya empezar a salirnos no de la
idea de que las personas del colectivo
lgbtq más no pueden practicar fútbol o
cualquier otro deporte o no debieran
hacerlo o deben mantenerse su sexualidad
oculta
Bueno me parece que es algo que queda
para atrás y que ya estamos dando vuelta
la página porque estamos hablando del
torneo deportivo más importante del
mundo más que los Juegos Olímpicos y más
que cualquier otra cuestión no entonces
creo que está esta vidriera de Qatar fue
muy importante así como lo fue el
mundial de fútbol femenino en Francia en
2019 el que pudimos estar en algún
partido y también las reivindicaciones
para las mujeres hicieron escuchar muy
fuerte y Esperamos que sigan en este
sentido cuando tengamos en 2023 el
mundial de Nueva Zelanda y Australia
Mónica bueno hablaba usted recién de el
fútbol como un hecho político un hecho
cultural verdad hacia esto apunta a mi
próxima pregunta no un hecho que
trasciende lo puramente deportivo una
mujer jugando al fútbol o sea una mujer
moviéndose en una cancha estamos
hablando de un espacio que durante
muchísimo tiempo fue exclusivo para los
hombres está conquistando un espacio es
un hecho político revolucionario
sí estoy convencida de que es un hecho
político revolucionario como como muy
bien señalas porque estamos hablando de
la propia experiencia estamos hablando
de lo que nos pasa en nuestra
organización social que es en Buenos
Aires en la villa 31 en un lugar con
pocas posibilidades donde las mujeres
atraviesan
montones de situaciones que tienen que
ver con la pobreza con la vulnerabilidad
social y ahí conquistando el terreno la
cancha de fútbol que durante mucho
tiempo Solamente podían entrar Los
varones eso significó para ese conjunto
de compañeras un cambio absolutamente
revolucionario porque estamos hablando
de los tiempos que las mujeres le
podemos dedicar a jugar y el tiempo que
le dedicamos a las tareas de cuidado y
que eso en un barrio las mujeres adoptan
esas conductas se da muy temprana y los
permisos para jugar son muy escasos
Entonces cuando se logra conquistar un
territorio que está a la vista de toda
la comunidad cuando se logra establecer
un entrenamiento para jugar al fútbol
cada vez mejor digamos no es solamente
tirar la pelota un rato bueno queremos
ser buena futbolistas y entender lo que
pasa con el cuerpo los vínculos el
territorio y el lenguaje no son los
cuatro ejes donde sostenemos nuestro
nuestro trabajo es muy revolucionario
ver una chica que llega con la cabeza
agachada con su autoestima destruida
pensando que no puede hacer otra cosa de
su vida que la que le plantearon el
fútbol le está mostrando otro cristal el
fútbol ayuda abrir esa perspectiva y
abrir esa cabeza cuando levantas la
vista puedes pasar la pelota a tus
compañeras y fundamentalmente te das
cuenta que las transformaciones son
colectivas y en eso el fútbol nos deja
una una enseñanza maravillosa no por eso
hablamos de fútbol feminista y
describimos como fútbol feminista todo
ese proceso donde una niña una joven un
adolescente se pudo parar sobre sus
derechos aprenderlos ejercerlos a partir
del deporte nacional no del deporte que
en Argentina significa todo lo que
significa que es mucho más que la cancha
de fútbol y que también ocurren en otras
partes del mundo en Sudamérica
particularmente Mónica muy vinculado a
esto que usted estaba diciendo que es
tan interesante no entonces podríamos
decir que el fútbol se ha transformado
en una militancia clave para los
feminismos
Sí sí yo puedo referirme al proceso que
vivimos en Argentina porque es el que
conocemos y protagonizamos a partir del
2015 lo que significó el movimiento ni
una menos en Argentina cuando se salió a
las calles para decir basta a la ola de
femicidios en ese momento de feminismo
en Argentina se popularizó hubo una
cantidad de compañeras a lo largo y a lo
ancho del país manifestándose en las
calles y creemos que ese momento
político fue una bisagra para que el
derecho a jugar el fútbol entre en la
agenda del movimiento de mujeres algo
que no había ocurrido hasta ahí en ese
momento también se daban todas las
discusiones por la ley de interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo por el derecho
al aborto la legalización del aborto en
Argentina entonces hablando desde el
cuerpo desde nuestros derechos a decidir
sobre nuestros cuerpos ahí el deporte y
el jugar es absolutamente clave no
también Tuvimos una participación
importante en lo que fue esa batalla
como futbolistas entonces creo que
como los tópicos no los puntos altos en
los que nos permitió
pararnos políticamente para seguir
transformando a partir del fútbol y eso
lo creemos cruciales esencial por eso
hablamos de militancia por eso hablamos
del feminismo y por eso creemos que que
otro fútbol es posible no abierto claro
con canchas donde todos los cuerpos
puedan entrar y con personas que
fundamentalmente puedan disfrutar de un
juego que es maravilloso y que explica
nuestra cultura explica nuestros barrios
explica nuestros clubes incluso también
nuestras familias cuando te pones a
hablar o conversar bueno Porque esos
hincha de este crudo porque es
simpatizas por este Club y no por otro
hay una línea Familiar no para explicar
eso como también para explicar la la
alegría callejera desbordante explotó
con el triunfo de la selección argentina
en Qatar Mónica Santino se pasó
rapidísimo a la entrevista Muchísimas
gracias por haber participado de este
encuentro en Frank 24 en español
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes siempre a
disposición un abrazo grande Gracias una
vez más y a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
Franz 24.com sigan junto a nosotros
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]